nineteen years as a cop and self-defense
expert have taught Gary Fredo to be
prepared to anticipate the unexpected
but what makes an expert's response so
effective a prepared response is quick
decisive and focused on a vulnerable
target like the pelvis technology
reveals the anatomical secrets of this
strikingly effective target the pelvis
is the human body's structural center
like a building's foundation it supports
everything above break the pelvis and
the body can fall like a house of cards
sound difficult the architecture of this
foundation has a built-in weakness this
is where experts strike the pubis it's
not bone that you're actually hitting
but it's a connection who to bones and
so that does form a weak point the
structure is actually a ring and when
you break the ring you can see how it
would potentially break right here it
takes up to 400 pounds of force to break
the pelvis can one quick strike
delivered that much force and if so will
it disable an attacker Dominic DeVito is
trained to deliver such a strike
David Abel's pressure profile system
will measure the force of the strike a
sensor pad fixed to the bag will
determine if Dominic's technique truly
has pelvis breaking power
we're ready to collect data we're ready
three two what a simple strength with
the palm of the hand 384 pounds of force
surprising even to the scientists well
it's right at about the 400 level so I
have to admit that's uh that's more
force than I thought he was gonna
generate yeah it's at the level we're
breaking the pubic bone is definitely a
possibility but is it enough force to
take down an attacker to determine if
the pubic bone would break takes a
different dummy Dominic what we have
here now is we have a skeleton and it
has internal organs we have a bladder
colon and we have all the pelvic bones
here so when you actually impact us it
should be fairly realistic as to what
you would actually feel in the human
body if you were to impact with this
pelvic strike in the real world the
counter strike would likely surprise the
attacker he would be as unprepared to
move as a dummy
what
did bone break a little exploratory
surgery will tell this might be one of
the more unusual surgeries I've ever
done oh yeah it looks like the front of
the pelvic bone is separated now so it's
fractured yeah normally you see this in
only high velocity car crashes and so
this that you know continues to surprise
me frankly that that we're seeing this
much injury 384 pounds of self-defense
from a strike that traveled less than
three feet it's all about Anatomy
this is the structural secret of a
self-defense strike
no ring-shaped pelvis is a fused group
of bones secured by the tough ligaments
and cartilage of the pubic joint
yet within this fault line lies its
weakness the strike winds just above the
joint its energy spreads like a wave to
the bladder intestine and colon
thrusting the organs back against the
pelvic bone moving with enough force the
strike can fracture the pelvic ring with
the pubis fractured standing becomes
difficult
walking nearly impossible without the
integrity of the pelvic ring the body
becomes top-heavy and the attacker
collapses